fumer économie c'est le début
aujourd'hui de la 7e fête de l'internet
un français sur trois serait désormais
connectés et la fameuse révolution
annoncée est bien en marche
exemple les achats en ligne ils ont fait
un bond de 56% l'an dernier explication
les transactions sont de plus en plus
sécurisés david bowie régis mater pour
régler ses achats sur internet il faut
presque toujours taper sur son
ordinateur
les seize chiffres de sa carte bancaire
mais de nombreux consommateurs refusent
d'utiliser ce moyen de paiement
cet inventeur a donc eu une idée simple
pour les convaincre
finalement tout le monde a un téléphone
à côté de soi quand on est sur internet
et on s'est demandé pourquoi on
n'utiliserait pas le clavier ce
téléphone en même temps que le clavier
de l'ordinateur démonstration le client
tape les huit premiers chiffres de sa
carte bancaire donne un numéro de
téléphone est valide sa commande
quelques secondes plus tard il reçoit
automatiquement un appel
les huit derniers chiffres sont alors
transmis par téléphone la banque peut
autoriser la transaction impossible pour
un pirate de reconstituer tout le puzzle
ce système est déjà utilisé depuis noël
chez l'un des plus grands cybermarchands
français dans la région de bordeaux
près d'un million et demi de clients
achètent ici des dvd du matériel
informatique ou même de l'électroménager
en fait 15 8 euros par jour d'eau pour
son audience au 3 3 400 personnes qu'ils
ont tenu ce samedi
on peut penser que la plupart du
téléphone mobile que l'on a très vite ça
va se développer un service qui
intéresse également cette entreprise qui
vend des voyages sur internet car au
moment de payer certains clients
hésitent encore à sortir leur carte
bancaire votre téléphone
on a toujours beaucoup de visiteurs qui
démarre une transaction chez nous dans
qui en très loin dans la transaction et
puis arrivé à la poche de paiement
ça ne vous dit pas car il faut encore
rassurer les consommateurs les plus
inquiets la fraude représente pourtant
aujourd'hui moins d'un pour cent des
transactions sur internet